[Musique]
bonjour ravi de vous retrouver ici
depuis strasbourg depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro nous allons
ouvrir ensemble les portes de l'europe
et voici le programme une européenne sur
trois au moins est victime au cours de
sa vie de violences physiques ou
sexuelles d'un pays à l'autre
les réponses et les disparités sont très
différentes en france alors des
conclusions du grenelle
une femme meurt encore tous les deux
jours sous les coups de son conjoint ou
ex-conjoint comment lutter contre ce
fléau qui gangrène nos sociétés est
avant tout une question de moyens nous
prendrons la direction de l'espagne qui
fait figure de modèle dans la lutte
contre les violences conjugales et les
féminicides et nous en débattrons avec
nos invités en plateau mais avant tout
ce qu'il ne fallait pas louper dans
l'actualité européenne cette semaine de
l'élection présidentielle en roumanie à
l'investiture de la nouvelle commission
européenne s'est résumé pour vous par
aurait aidé à face
le libéral claus ioannis remporte
l'élection présidentielle en roumanie
avec plus de 63% des voix il est très
largement réélu son adversaire du parti
social démocrate ne récolte que 37% des
suffrages
un lourd échec pour ce parti qui a
dominé la vie politique roumaine depuis
la chute du régime communiste
il y a trente ans ces résultats marquent
notamment la volonté des roumains de
lutter contre la corruption
le bric site au coeur de la campagne
pour les législatives au royaume uni le
premier ministre conservateur boris
johnson met en avant son principal atout
l'accord de retrait déjà négocier avec
bruxelles
son opposant travailliste jeremy corbyn
propose lui de négocier un nouvel accord
de sortie puis de le soumettre au vote
lors d'un second référendum sur le break
site
une option qui ne semble pas séduire les
électeurs
les travaillistes sont loin derrière les
conservateurs dans les sondages le parti
de boris johnson est crédité de 40 % des
intentions de vote
différences d'approché ou échange
houleux
la tension semble monter entre angela
merkel et emmanuel macron les propos du
président français sur l'otan
un organisme en état de mort cérébrale
selon lui n'ont pas été bien perçue
outre-rhin selon le new york times
la chancelière allemande lui aurait fait
part de son énervement lors d'un dîner à
berlin
je comprends votre désir d'une politique
de rupture mais j'en ai assez de
ramasser les morceaux
le parlement européen a investi
officiellement la nouvelle commission
cinq mois après l'élection de
l'allemande ursula von der leyen au
poste de présidente
la commission européenne prendra ses
fonctions le 1er décembre
sur les 26 commissaires initialement
désigné trois ont été écartés par le
parlement européen dont la française
sylvie goulard
c'est donc avec un mois de retard sur le
calendrier initial que le parlement
valident la composition définitive de la
nouvelle commission européenne
et j'accueille sur ce plateau francis
gutmann vous êtes secrétaire général de
la maison de l'europe bonjour et lorenzo
consoli vous êtes journaliste italien
chez à skynews bienvenue à tous les deux
avant de revenir avec vous sur les
grands dossiers qui attendent la
nouvelle commission européenne
je voulais avoir votre sentiment sur la
façon dont elle a été conçue sur les
difficultés on sait que trois
commissaires ont été retoqués dont la
française sylvie goulard est ce que
d'emblée ça fragilise ursula von der
leyen et son équipe
bonjour je voudrais juste préciser donc
que c'est la maison de l'europe
strasbourg alsace donc je suis un peu le
local de l'étape
oui et je dirais qu'au contraire ça
renforce la commission parce que ce
processus dont qui a duré depuis les
élections européennes de mai 2019 une a
conduit à sélectionner des commissaires
et à les auditionner en fonction de
leurs compétences et aussi qui n'est pas
de problèmes judiciaires qu'il puisse
arriver
donc je dirais qu'au contraire c'est un
processus démocratique qui a permis
d'aboutir des meilleures candidatures et
donc je pense que le rôle de la
commission est renforcée grâce à cet
examen
vous partagez également à cet avis ac je
crois que c'était très intéressant de
voir combien le rôle du parlement
européenne
c'est vraiment établie dans ce procès ce
processus de sélection des commissaires
on ne peut vraiment pas ignorer le
parlement et la présidente élue a en
effet fini oui c'est ça que cette
question de légitimité d'ailleurs il
faut dire que dans son aucun des pays
montre il y à un processus de sélection
aussi poussé aussi détaillés ou les les
commissaires vraiment sont devant une
commission d'examen où il doit vraiment
répondre aux questions en compte comme
des étudiants à l'université
c'est incroyable mais dans sa coque
aucun pays membre
il y à il ya ça pour les ministres dont
avec une nouvelle donne politique
importante ainsi que le nouvel exécutif
il ne dispose pas d'une majorité solide
au parlement européenne ça c'est quelque
chose qui va falloir prendre en compte
pour la future commission oui là encore
moi je vois plutôt les choses
na côté positif c'est dire que jusqu'à
présent il y avait un partage des
pouvoirs entre le groupe ppe les
populaire européen et socialisme et
démocratie
donc c'est ce qui s'est passé pour la
commission juncker ils se sont entendus
à deux groupes
maintenant ils ne peuvent plus le faire
donc ils ont dû composer avec le
troisième groupe lors de leur union est
un crime et il a fallu dans cette
période qu'on a connus que ursula von
der leyen à y voir les groupes
politiques pas seulement ces trois là
avaient tous les groupes politiques pour
essayer de comprendre leurs attentes
leurs espérances qui sont le résultat
des élections européennes de mai 2010
neuf où on a eu pour la première fois
depuis 25 ans plus de 50% de
participation donc c'est bien
les jeunes ont davantage participer donc
il fallait prendre en compte toutes ces
aspirations notamment celle des jeunes
et le green deal
donc je pense que c'est mieux pour la
démocratie veut s'asseoir sur trois
groupes que sur deux justement parlons
maintenant des grands dossiers ans qui
attend de la nouvelle équipe avec une
priorité exprimée par la présidente de
la commission sur la vente d'art leyen
on écoute je veux que la corvair
européen devienne la marque distinctive
de l'europe au coeur de cette stratégie
se trouve notre engagement à devenir le
premier continent climatique neutre du
monde et donc durant les cent premiers
jours à un demande à la commission veut
élaborer un green deal européen pour une
union européenne climatiquement neutre
d'ici 2050 lorenzo conflit est-ce que
cet objectif il est réaliste réalisable
il est réaliste et réalisable ça
dépendra évidemment des personnes s'il
est si les hommes les femmes juste son
holà la juste place et s'il y aura la
volonté politique des états membres
parce qu'il faut dire aussi que on l'a
vu plusieurs fois beaucoup dé dossiers
parfois la commission avance lll présent
des projets qui sont des projets
ambitieux valable nécessaires et à
saison les états membres qui bloque
c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui et ça
pourrait avoir le même effet
mobilisateur qui a eu le le
le projet de jacques delors de marché
unique pour toutes les rangs pour toute
l'économie européenne
c'est nécessaire pour l'environnement si
nécessaire pour le climat est nécessaire
pour la la société
mais c'est nécessaire aussi pour les
développements de l'économie parce que
je vu l'économie à bout de souffle
est ce que la commission va pouvoir
compter sur le soutien du parlement sur
ce terrain la commission a fait des
propositions et le parlement a renchéri
en ayant des objectifs plus ambitieux et
en fait c'est le reflet effectivement
des élections d'avoir le soutien des
jeunes parce que veulent les jeunes
c'est un avenir meilleur et que l'on une
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
avec davantage de moyens
et comme disait lorenzo le frein c'est
souvent les états membres donc je pense
qu'à une bonne alliance qui s'est établi
entre le parlement et la commission pour
pousser ses objectifs une des autres
priorités
c'est adapté l'europe à l'ère du
numérique est ce que l'europe en la
matière a pris beaucoup de retard et que
va faire que peut faire la commission
européenne ce qui manque à l'europe
c'est une politique à nous celle vers
l'innovation digitale avoir veste hague
l'a la vice président exécutif
vestiaires charge du digital est
terrible et on qui est quand même la
personne la plus compétente en la
matière a dit bon de l'aïe
pendant son discours c'est quand même
une garantie de de pouvoir réaliser ça
c'est ce n'est pas donné un des dossiers
sur la table c'est la gestion des
tensions commerciales quelle va être la
stratégie adoptée par la nouvelle
commission est ce qu'elle va durcir le
ton partenaire à durcir le ton c'est est
des états unis
on a on a maintenant une nouvelle
approche du côté de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et il faut que l'europe
soit plus forte pour réagir face à ce
partenaire qui joue plutôt le
bilatéralisme que le multilatéralisme
alors il ya eu peut-être aussi un
renversement d'opinion vis-à-vis de ces
accords commerciaux qu'on voit pointer
dans l'opinion mais il faut bien se dire
que l'économie mondiale fonctionne sur
les échanges
et il vaut mieux avoir des échanges
réguliers avec des clauses sociales
environnementales que des échanges
purement commerciaux qui existe de fait
mais il faut que c'est ça le but de
l'europe de la création de l'identité
européenne de l'union européenne d'avoir
des institutions fortes capables de
réserver à la chine aux états unis au
grand acteur émergent et il faut bien
reconnaître que l'europe a quand même
perdu un peu de sa puissance même si
elle est quand même au niveau commercial
la première puissance exportatrice avec
une donnée qu'il faut également intégrer
un c il faut s'attendre à une stagnation
de la croissance européenne
un ralentissement autour de 1 % de la
croissance dans les deux années à venir
ça il va falloir intégrer également oui
c'est justement pour ça que je parlais
d'un projet mobilisateur je crois qu est
vraiment là le projet de transition
écologique et climatique avec la
digitalisation de l'économie peuvent
vraiment mobiliser toutes les forces
actives de l'économie et donc oui il ya
un problème dont le pacte de stabilité
dans la dans la façon de gérer les
budgets publics
quand trop de rigidité rien contre
l'humanité même s'il ya oui même si on a
eu un petit peu également
il faut évoluer la dea dont il faut par
exemple à mon avis mais suppositions
très partagés en italie surtout il faut
que les investissements verts ne soient
pas comptées donc obtenir compte
organiser dans le pacte de stabilité
parce que ce sont des investissements
qui sont nécessaires et il faut de
l'argent il faut beaucoup d'argent pour
la transition écologique et ce sont des
investissements d'avenir qui vont
augmenter la croissance au pouvoir
convaincre là dessus l'allemagne les
pays bas et d'autres pays qui sont déjà
mais on n'a jamais été aussi proche de
les convaincre sur ce dont ces
questions-là sur les questions
écologiques et environnementales pour
conclure les eurosceptiques et
d'ailleurs et d'autres mettent souvent
en avant
la distance entre les institutions et
les citoyens européens là aussi c'est un
chantier à entreprendre pour cela vendre
mais son équipe oui je pense que
effectivement il faut que la commission
soit plus visible qu'elle soit plus
présente sur le terrain tu crois qu'il
faut regarder un peu les exemples
positifs par exemple il y as on a vu
avec la négociation sur le bric site
barnier a été un exemple magnifique de
transparence dans une négociation très
difficile si on est capable du jeu et la
transparence comme combary elle a fait
très très bien il faut prendre exemple
là les citoyens seront à même de
comprendre mieux les enjeux
par exemple dans les négociations
commerciales il n'a pas eu ça les
négociations commencèrent c'est vrai ce
sont des négociations de pédagogie oui
mais il faut surtout faire l'intérêt
public et donc n'est pas donnée on re
citoyens l'impression qui parfois une
impression fonds des caisses ce sont des
groupes d'intérêts qui ont leur leur jeu
en fait qu'ils sont qui qui font les
résultats finalement alors que c'est
l'intérêt public
là la chose la plus importante et c'est
la mission de la commission européenne
la démocratie merci à mes yeux à tous
les deux d'être venu sur notre plateau
on passe maintenant un tout autre sujet
les violences faites aux femmes une
femme sur trois est victime de violences
physiques ou sexuelles au cours de sa
vie et les européennes ne sont pas
épargnés en espagne on parle de violence
de genre le pays depuis plus de 15 ans a
mis en place un arsenal de mesures pour
tenter d'enrayer la tendance avec succès
c'est un reportage de flora sauvage
pendant douze ans erika a subi des
violences de la part de son conjoint
insultes humiliations menaces de mort
devant ses filles qui grandissent dans
la peur ce jour là je sortais de ce qui
était notre logement familial et il a
tenté d'emmener avec lui les enfants
j'ai essayé de discuter avec lui mais il
m'a mis un coup de poing dans le ventre
un jeune homme qui attendaient à l'arrêt
de bus nous a vus mais à ce moment là je
ne voulais pas porter plainte car
j'étais tétanisée j'avais très peur de
lui
une peur incontrôlable qu'erica un jour
réussir à surmonter grâce à ses filles
une nuit le père de mes filles est venu
en bas de chez moi pour commandeur il
est venu me crier dessus
il m'insultait par la fenêtre
mes filles ont eu tellement peur que
l'une d'entre elle s'est mise à vomir
à cet instant là je me suis dit que je
ne pouvais pas continuer à supporter
cette situation car elle avait des
conséquences sur mes filles
ce soir là j'ai été porté plainte au
commissariat
dans les heures qui suivent sa plainte
erica est reçu au tribunal en espagne la
loi oblige la justice à instruire les
dossiers de violences conjugales dans
les 72 heures qui suivent le dépôt de
plainte
l'objectif apporter une réponse rapide
aux victimes
le juge a ensuite 15 jours pour
organiser un procès et l'état peut se
substituer à la victime carlos est l'un
des cinq juges spécialisés du tribunal
de barcelone
comment s'est passé le contact physique
entre vous deux vous me le décrire quand
je prends une ordonnance de protection
je dois décider si je mets en place une
mesure anti rapprochement de l'agresseur
vis-à-vis de la victime
l'idée c'est que la victime soit
protégée tentent au niveau pénal qu'au
niveau civil
je peux envoyer l'agresseur en prison ou
lui faire porter un bracelet
électronique lui redonner un contrôle
s'il approche d'un certain périmètre à
proximité de la victime
je peux aussi décider d'une mesure de
protection 24 heures sur 24 pour la
victime depuis 2004 l'espagne s'est
dotée d'un arsenal juridique pour lutter
contre les violences conjugales au sein
du tribunal spécialisé de barcelone un
poste de soins et contigu au bureau du
juge
ici le médecin va examiner les victimes
qui porte plainte
s'il s'agit de violences physiques il y
a des éléments qui sont faciles à
détecter par n'importe quel
professionnel de la médecine comme des
blessures des bleus des conclusions il
ratera pas existé
et puis il y a les violences psychiques
et ce type d'agression on va l'évaluer à
travers un entretien avec les victimes
une formation spécifique est dispensée
aux professionnels pour ce juge cela est
primordial
ce n'est pas pareil de dénoncer une
tierce partie
et de dénoncer le père de ses enfants
avec lequel on vit
en quinze ans le pays a divisé par deux
le nombre de féminicide au prix d'un
vaste effort des autorités tribunaux
spécialisés formation des magistrats et
des policiers protection des victimes
200 millions d'euros sont injectés
chaque année pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes
devenu une grande cause nationale tchuss
63 ans est une survivante
elle se consacre aujourd'hui à une
association qui aide les femmes
pour elle ce qui a changé en espagne
c'est la prise de conscience de ce fléau
par la société toute entière selon les
nations unies la violence contre les
femmes
si le clean qui fait le plus de victimes
au monde bien plus que les crimes de
guerre où le terrorisme est donc ce qui
s'est passé à un moment donné ici en
espagne c'est qu'il a fallu nommer les
choses et mettre des mots dessus
la loi espagnole dit clairement que la
violence de genre c'est la violence qui
s'exerce par les hommes contre les
femmes
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'elles
sont des femmes ce soir là dans les rues
de barcelone des femmes battent le pavé
pour les organisations féministes
la loi espagnole ne va pas assez loin
après la décision d'un juge qui a refusé
de qualifier de viol
un fait divers concernant une jeune
fille de 15 ans inconsciente abusée
sexuellement par un groupe d'hommes les
manifestants réclament une modification
du code pénal ils l'ont violée
même si elle ne leur a pas dit non ça
reste un viol ce n'est pas une agression
donc il faut modifier le code pénal j'ai
67 ans et je suis ici dans la rue pour
lutter et je continuerai à lutter pour
toutes les filles et toutes les femmes
d'espagne et du monde entier de 71
féminicide en 2003 l'espagne est passé à
47 en 2018
trois fois moins qu'en france où l'on
compte déjà pas loin de 100 40 meurtres
de femmes par leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint depuis le début de l'année 2019
il
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir crise ou
l'asacar ou pulu bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputée française à la rue m vous si
j'ai donc ici au sein du groupe we knew
et je précise que vous présidiez le
groupe de travail sur les violences
économiques lors du grenelle des
violences conjugales en france à vos
côtés et dean régnèrent vous êtes
autrichienne vous sujet au sein du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates au
parlement et au parlement vous est
également la présidente de la commission
des droits de la femme et l'égalité des
genres bienvenue à toutes les deux je
voudrais que l'on revienne sur ce
reportage puisqu'on va le voir un modèle
espagnol qui fonctionne pourquoi est ce
que tous les pays européens ne suivent
pas ce modèle là c'est une belle
question qui en fait je peux pas vous
répondre pourquoi mais ça qui on a pu
constater à sept documentaires et qui
essaie un travail et de longue date
ça fait depuis 2004 qu'est l'espagne
travailler et sur l'échangé des
violences faites aux femmes et de
l'autre côté c'est une volonté politique
il a une volonté politique en 2004 et
après est devenue la cause nationale
vous voyez qu'il y à un peuple qui veut
combattre ces phénomènes
alors aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya la
même volonté à france et j'espère qu'ils
aussi pour les autres pays
ça va être une priorité est ce qu'au
niveau de l'europe il peut y avoir un
consensus sur cette question là sur ce
combat contre les violences faites à la
convention diskan brûle ça c'est
vraiment un instrument un instrument
fort là commence à istanbul expliqué
pour les utilisateurs c'est une
convention qui dit non non à toutes
sortes violence et qui demandent des
mesures au niveau des états et ce sont
les 4 ap qui sont là dedans c'est la
prévention mesures politiques protection
des femmes et aussi bien sur les mesures
de
nous relations la punition on va là les
réparer et c'est à dire nous devrons
faire des mesures partout en europe donc
il faut vraiment une stratégie générale
mais alors justement c'est intéressant
la convention istanbul elle a été
ratifiée par l'union européenne est là
et qu'elle a été ratifié par 21 états
membres ce qui veut dire qu'il ya encore
sept états membres qui n'ont pas ratifié
surtout les pays de l'est de l'europe
pas seulement mais surtout la bulgarie
la pologne la hongrie où il ya vraiment
une mentalité une culture de macho la
femme est la propriété de l'homme et
voilà et toutes sortes violence ça ce
sont des conséquences donc ils ne
veulent pas parler de la violence
conjugale de la violence domestique la
violence de l'ardennais révèle même
directement paris en espagne on parle de
violence de jong
heureusement heureusement il faut dans
ce combat contre la violence faite aux
femmes
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est avant
tout une question de moyens c'est sous
la saga au boulou non non je vais je
vais dire qui je pense que c'est
vraiment une mentalité qu'il faut que sa
chance c'est essayer de travailler à
long terme bien sûr les moyens sont
importants et vous avez pu voir qui est
le gouvernement d'edouard philippe il a
mis les moyens en autriche dans votre
fil et leurs nerfs
il n ous des féminicides ces dernières
années y at il eu une réponse de la part
du gouvernement autrichien et si oui
laquelle
les années passent et on a diminué le
nombre des foyers pour les femmes
battues
en autriche on a vraiment diminué les
les
la monnaie voilà les moyens pour pour
les organisations qui aident aux femmes
et voilà on voit tout de suite le
résultat il faut les numéros téléphone
on peut téléphoner tout de suite à
quelqu'un qui en danger on a besoin des
mesures pour la police pour les médecins
pour bien reconnaître qu est ce que
s'est passé à cette femme qui va là bas
c'est à dire c'est aussi vraiment un
grand devoir politique
les mots sont importants car les
violences là ce ne sont pas des faits
divers comme les autres il est important
de les caractériser ces violences les
mots on parle de féminicide dans
certains pays depuis peu mais pas dans
tous les pays en espagne nous parle de
violence de genre est ce que ça les mots
sont les mots et maux ts sont également
importants l'élément ils ont un pouvoir
politique
c est sûr que par exemple quand je
parlais avec l est
les espagnols on m'a parlé par exemple
qui est pour avancer que puisse avancer
vite ils ont utilisé les mots terrorise
machiste par exemple qui est comme ça et
le fameux sont aidés comme si c'était le
terrorisme etc en parler avec evelyne
qui et c'est beaucoup plus facile de
parler de terrorisme mais pas de parler
des féminicides et justin contraire
quand les des journaux en autriche
souvent quand s'est vraiment passé
une femme qui était étranglée meurtre et
par un ex amie parfois ces cris ou
souvent s'écrie c'est une tragédie
familiale une tragédie d'amour et quand
on utilise des mots comme ça on fait
toute l'histoire petit et pas très
importante donc sert à rien de parler le
gouvernement français il vient de
dévoiler différentes mesures dans le
cadre du grenelle des violences bon
nombre d'associations quand même se sont
dit déçus qu'est ce que vous répondez à
celles et ceux qui sont déçus par les
annonces du gouvernement français vous
avez participé à ce grenelle en fruits
alors moi j'ai dit quelque chose parce
que je suis médecin
j'ai une association s'est dit avant
d'être dessus il faut saluer le courage
des marlins chapa qu'il a pris ses
sujets il a ramené à l'actualité et
qu'il y a un gouvernement aujourd'hui
qui s'engage j'appelle aussi à tous les
associations qui donnent le temps d
évaluation et c'est pourquoi j'ai dit
cette volonté il faut que je sois une
volonté de tout le monde y compris les
associations
si dans un an on peut et on peut voir ou
ognier il faut reparler mais commençons
à être positif pour une fois d'accord je
vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter un le
premier ministre français edouard
philippe qui a détaillé une des mesures
dont on a beaucoup parlé lorsque cela
peut sauver des vies
offrir la possibilité aux médecins de
déroger au secret
je souhaite que cela concerne des cas
très strictes encadrent et les cas
d'urgence absolue où il existe un risque
sérieux de renouvellement alors vous
vous nous l'avez dit vous êtes médecin
gynécologue est ce que vous étiez pour
la levée du secret médical sachant que
les médecins sont partagés sur la
question
je me suis trouvé à l'hôpital avec une
femme enceinte qui ne te battue par son
mari et j'aurais aimé beaucoup appelé la
police elle a protégé ce que vous n'avez
pas pu faire à l'époque c'est ça oui
dans le combat contre les violences
faites aux femmes et il faut être allé
au delà en termes d'égalité des droits
de parité l'union européenne sur ces
questions là est ce que l'on fait
suffisamment assez vous êtes présidente
de la commission réussi des droits des
femmes au parlement européen oui il faut
pas beaucoup plus tout d'abord vraiment
une stratégie générale contre la
violence à l'égard des femmes et du
jeune fille une vraie stratégie est là
une chose est super importante c'est
l'autre que les femmes sont autonomes
qui ne ce qui ne se sont pas dépendants
des hommes c'est à dire une femme qui
travaille une femme qui s'occupe de son
argent est beaucoup plus sur le côté
safe sécurisé qu'une femme qui ne peut
pas quitter un homme violent qui de
pendant parce que vous allez et donc
c'est aussi le devoir de l'état d'offrir
des moyens et ça commence avec avec
toutes sortes mesures pour pour les
femmes pour pour avoir plus de gagner
vous au parlement européen qu'est ce que
vous pouvez faire justement dans ce
combat là à la différence en ce qui
concerne les salaires hommes/femmes doit
vraiment être diminuée et ça tout de
suite
on a besoin des mesures et on attendra
la commission maintenant des présentes
et assez rapidement une proposition les
violences économiques vous avez
travaillé dessus vous avez présidé ce
groupe de travail dans le cadre du
grenelle en france
vous partagez évidemment la vie divine
lumière oui bien sûr les violences
économiques
ça veut dire que quelqu'un il le gère
ton argent qui on travaille on
travaillait pas ça veut dire ça et alors
nous on a fait beaucoup de propositions
et par exemple qu'il soit plus facile
quand une femme est un vaillant une
banque d'avoir un compte pour elle même
qui est par exemple quand elle
travaillait puisse avoir une formation
du personnel comme ça si elle a besoin
d'aidé partir à une autre ville pour
être à sécurité qu'ils puissent être
accompagnés
levin régnèrent les mots de la fin on va
vous les laissez est-ce que vous avez un
mot d'espoir pour les européennes qui
nous regardent maintenant nous avons
avoir une commission jen d'apple est
c'est à dire nous avons beaucoup de
femmes dans la politique qui est
vraiment en train de se battre et de
demander et pas seulement demander de
travailler activement en ce qui concerne
toutes sortes mesures contre la violence
mais aussi pour la vraie égalité hommes
femmes prennent bien merci à toutes les
deux est venu ce sont les mots de la fin
merci c'est la fin de cette émission
vous pouvez la voir en replay sur les
sites internet des chaînes
parlementaires mais aussi sur l'antenne
de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures open
[Musique]